mon fils
bonjour à tous donc bienvenue sur nère
7,4 tv dans l'émission du conseil
général des jeunes donc aujourd'hui nous
allons parler donc de visage c'est les
réseaux sociaux non ce plateau nous
avons donc ça à la présidente de la
commission est et puis donc prescilla la
présidente de la commission nord est ce
que vous êtes inscrits sur des réseaux
sociaux oui moi je suis inscrite sur
twitter facebook instagram et et skype
d'accord moi je suis inscrit sur twitter
et instagram défroqué et pourquoi êtes
vous inscrit tôt des réseaux sociaux
bien moi en fait je me suis inscrite sur
twitter c'était pour pouvoir suivre
l'actualité rester connecté sur facebook
c'était pour pouvoir garder contact avec
mes amis et pouvoir discuter avec eux
instagram c'était pour poster des photos
et surtout voilà pour ça raconte un peu
ma vie et skype c'était pour pour
communiquer avec mes amis d'accord et
pour toi plus il a pourquoi es tu
laisses q donc les réseaux sociaux mais
comme ça râle a dit pour moi twitter
c'est pour
pour communiquer avec mes amis et bien
souvent l'actualité et instagram c'est
pour poster les photos de moi de mes de
ma vie de ma famille de mes amis et
c'est dire notre mot clé et toi sa
mairie donc moi j'utilise donc des
réseaux sociaux tels que facebook
twitter skype et instagram nous bien sûr
j'utilise donc pourra être en contact
avec mes amis et puis donc fait passer
des messages aussi donc pour les
convocations au conseil général des
jeunes donc voila et puis je poste des
photos de moi et puis de ma famille
d'accord alors donc pour toi puis s'il
est ce que vraiment c'est important
aujourd'hui pour un ado d'avoir facebook
devance twitter d'avoir skype donc
qu'elle est un yb a d'un côté oui parce
que si un ado n'a pas vraiment n'a pas
de réseaux sociaux et bien ils seraient
pas au courant des dernières actualités
et bien sûr répond qu'il pourra pas
communiquer avec ses amis et ce rapport
est par exemple nous faisons des sorties
il sera pas au courant ce qu'on fasse
le week-end entre amis d'accord ok pour
toi donc ça va bien pour moi ça a son
importance mais c'est pas forcément
obligatoire il ya des gens qui vivent
sans qu'ils ont besoin d'amis qui
sortent par exemple j'ai des amis ils
n'ont pas de réseaux sociaux il s'en
sort très bien ça entre les commandes et
santi et du coup tout se passe bien mais
ça quand même un peu l'important si on
veut vraiment savoir ce qui se passe
dans le monde en fait d'accord ok donc
nous allons suivre donc avec un premier
témoignage alors il ya quelqu'un que je
connaissais pas donc vous avez aucun ami
en commun avec lui et je me suis rendu
compte par hasard qui prenais mes photos
je fais des chansons leur profil et
toutes ces photos c'était des photos de
moi et de mes amis et je me suis rendu
compte parce qu'il a commencé à demander
tous mes amis autour de moi
donc
des amis m'ont signalé et donc j'ai
signalé ce compte et je demandais à tous
mes amis de le scénario si depuis une
semaine sont contactés ce pas donc
quelles sont vos réactions par rapport à
ce garçon qui a témoigné qui a donc il y
avait des personnes qui ont pris des
photos son compte et on écrit un autre
quelles sont vos réactions donc
pour toi ça
c'est dans ces cas là qu'on voit que
faut vraiment faire attention à ce qu'on
met sur facebook surtout en ce qui
concerne les fautes d'autres parce que
ça peut nous suivre après c'est pas très
intelligent ça serait pas intelligent de
bons que ça nous porte préjudice
mais en ce qui me concerne je suis
d'accord avec eux
le garçon passe de primo il a fait
passer le message à ses camarades pour
qu'ils puissent
bloquer la personne et voilà donc à sa
place je ferais la même chose avec mes
amis et ensuite et bien comme dit sarah
ben oui il faut faire vraiment attention
de ce qu'on fait sur les réseaux sociaux
quelle faute où nous mettons par exemple
si nous envoyons une photo à un petit
copain et que notre petit copain mais
bien qu'on a cassé avec lui et que lui
il se vend schéma il fera tourner la
photo est donc c'est pas trés oui voila
je suis d'accord avec le garçon à sa
place je ferais la même chose j'avais
retiré tous les cas tous mes amis pour
qu'ils puissent bloquer la personne et
je suis aussi d'accord avec sarah on
doit faire attention et regarder quelles
photos nous mettons sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple s'il ya une fille
qui lance une photo à son petit copain
tout au privé et bien que les deux
casses et d'un
bain pour se venger le petit copain lui
va faire tout à la photo et ce sera
atteinte à son image et donc voilà il y
aura beaucoup de problèmes et voilà des
conséquences aussi voilà justement donc
je suis vraiment d'accord avec vous il
faut vraiment faire attention donc ce
qu'on met ce facebook surtout les photos
privées
et puis un moment c'est un problème
vraiment exorbitants donc de faire cela
donc de porter atteinte à l'image
l'identité d'une personne donc ben pas
poursuivre donc nous avons un deuxième
témoignage donc c'est les mauvaises
rencontres sur les réseaux sociaux as tu
déjà été victime de harcèlement puis est
ce que tu peux nous raconter ouais ben
en fait on a ajouté et c'était un gars
et il me disait qu'il m'aimait mais moi
je l'aimé pas donc il marche et il
disait comme ça bah oui si tu sors pas
avec moi ou bien si tu fais pas un
effort de mémé ben je viens de voir et
je tort c'est vrai je te ferai des trucs
pas faisable quoi donc j'ai dit non mais
tu perds la tête ou quoi db nantes
simplement ben voila je me tue même des
bêtes c'est quoi un mois je suis pas sur
mon compte c'est pas écrit cherche un
mec a aimé et puis voilà battant quoi il
va chercher notre me fire nom qui m'ont
dit non mais je m'en fiche mais il faut
que tu m'aimais tout non mais ça va pas
voir
d'ici ça va très bien et moi je réponds
non alors qu'elles sont déjà donc vos
réactions recommencer sur ce problème
donc darche allemand
qui à chaque fois on recommence
bien c'est vrai qu'avec cette vidéo on
peut voir que faut vraiment non
seulement fin attention à ce qu'on met
comme image mais surtout faire attention
avec qui on parle parce que même s'il y
a un profil avec une photo on sait
jamais vraiment ça peut être quelqu'un
d'autre ça peut ça peut être vraiment
dangereux comme comme on a pu le voir
dans la vidéo et il faut vraiment faire
le nécessaire pour ne pas tomber dans le
piège d'accord pour toi puis si la
caisse que quelle est ta réaction donc
face à ce témoignage donc d'art
seulement bah pour moi je suis d'accord
avec sarah on ne sait pas vraiment qui
est derrière la photo ou dell prénom
sur le profil donc il faut vraiment
attention par exemple si vous voyez la
photo d'un petit garçon d'un adolescent
dont vous ne savez pas si derrière il ya
un adolescent ou une adulte par exemple
ma connerie à une connaissance elle a eu
une rendez vous un rendez vous avec un
adolescent quelqu'un de son âge un
soi-disant et donc elle est partie à ce
rendez vous et elle a vu que c'était un
adulte donc elle a rebroussé chemin et
lui a posé un lapin et ensuite elle est
repartie sociaux et la bloquer et
ensuite à m'en parler avec ses parents
et bien sûr les la cpe de son collège
voilà donc
donc voilà donc comme vous l'aviez dire
donc face à ce problème face à ce
témoignage donc il faut bien sûr en
parler donc à des personnes un adulte à
vos parents ou bien sinon à des
intervenants donc du collège ou même le
psychologue du collège au pire donc
justement voit un port stopper donc le
harcèlement donc au collège il y a une
mais revers donc les mis en place par le
ministère de l'éducation
donc qui est le 08 08 81 70 10 le 08 08
81 70 10 justement pour comme je voulais
dis donc dialoguer déjà avec des
spécialistes et puis pour donner des
conseils qui peuvent justement vous
aider dans votre problème voilà donc je
vous remercie donc d'avoir répondu à
rien et puis à la prochaine pour une
nouvelle émission du conseil général des
jeunes
et